good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight last year unbeknownst to
pretty much nobody a woman in Brooklyn
started a Twitter account that was
comprised almost solely of videos of
liberals talking about themselves
so the concept was very simple find
interesting tape that had already been
uploaded to the Internet by the people
who made it and then repost that tape
there was no editing of it no special
effects there was very little editorial
content the idea was to let activist
types describe in their own words what
they believe unfiltered
the owner created it called that account
Libs of tick tock Libs of tick tock now
has more followers than the entire
population of the state of Wyoming lives
of tick tock's audience dwarfs the
nightly viewership on CNN
so it was quite Successful by definition
the question is why and here's why it
turns out that as repellent as academic
lifestyle liberalism may seem to you as
an observer the reality of it as
described by the people who actually
believe this stuff is even worse than
you ever imagined it's really beyond
belief both idiotic and disgusting it's
like watching someone eat roadkill you
feel nauseous but you can't turn away
so lives of tick tock found all kinds of
tape on the internet but they found a
bunch of selfie Style videos from the
publicly available social media accounts
of teachers they didn't Snoop they just
pulled people had already posted here's
some of what they found
us and I'm a preschool teacher recently
we started wearing pronouns
the kids get to pick
to pick pronoun pin everything
every single day and we had some that
changed up so I'm a non-binary preschool
teacher and my kids know I'm non-binary
they know I'm not a girl or a boy I use
they them pronouns in the classroom we
work on it not all the kids get it
that's okay and I go by mixed gray in
the classroom not miss or Mr Man y'all
thought me teaching the children about
me being Polly was crazy but not only
that but they also know that I'm gender
fluid I'm gonna give you my explanation
about what it means to be transgender as
well so when babies are born the doctor
looks at them and they make a guess
about whether the baby is a boy or a
girl it's as young as three and four are
actually aware of their gender identity
even if they don't have the language for
it say that pre-k through third grade
are not ready for such topics is
actually internalized homophobia and
transphobia
so those are the people in charge of
tending to your small children's Minds
while you're at work now maybe you agree
with the views you just heard maybe you
think that doctors just guess at the sex
of newborns maybe you don't agree it
almost doesn't matter either way you
have a right as a parent to know what
these people are teaching to your
children
and yet before lives of tick tock there
was not an easy way to find out what
they were teaching I take the teacher's
word for it
well it turns out there are an awful lot
of videos like this out there Libs of
tick tock found a lot of them here for
example is the scene at one private
school in Washington DC
that's right now
okay so let's say you're paying 45 000 a
year to send your kids to some overrated
mediocre private school in the District
of Columbia you think everything's fine
you pull up lives of tick tock and you
find out what's actually happening in
your kids classroom what's wrong with
that
this is journalism no news organization
in America has done more to reveal the
reality within American schools than
Libs of tick tock we heard a number of
their videos on the show we are grateful
for their reporting it was far more
straightforward than anything you're
going to find in the New York Times or
the Washington Post because it wasn't
accompanied by a lot of blow feeding
they just showed you the tape and you
could decide that's journalism here's
another piece of tape that lives of tick
tock Unearthed that amazed and horrified
us this is a teacher screaming at a
student for refusing to wear a mask
you're playing are you playing no I'm
not all of us I will call the police
I'm serious
yeah
are you serious yeah I am serious man I
haven't had enough of it I knew you were
going to take off your mask the moment I
turned the corner
so enjoy Bia
that's an instant school suspension
where you have to sit and run with the
military guy all day
because you're a piece
I'm gonna call the police he screeches
because the kid has the mask beneath his
nose
now again maybe you're okay with your
kids being taught by emotionally
incontinent Nut Cases like that maybe
you're not but you probably ought to
know either way so you can see why Libs
of tick tock quickly became so very
popular you didn't have to Wade through
some long editorial to find out what was
actually happening you could see the raw
video and again you could assess it for
yourself
millions of parents are grateful for
that so is Christina Pusha who's the
press secretary for the governor of
Florida Ron DeSantis it was partly in
response to videos that she saw on Libs
of tick tock that Florida ultimately
banned Public School teachers from
lecturing kindergartners about sex
that's no law it's one of those popular
laws in the state the majority of
Democrats support it so lives of tick
tock was getting results as good
journalism does not bad for a Twitter
feed so of course that Twitter feed had
to be shut down the bite Administration
and its many servants in the news media
set to work the neoliberal slander
machine Media Matters published four
separate hit pieces on lives of tick
tock in just the past three weeks it was
trafficking hate for allowing liberals
to talk about themselves it was anti-gay
hahaha as if the site was attacking
anyone surely was not attacking gaze he
was just playing tape of people talking
about themselves in their own words
video that they uploaded
well Twitter could not stand this they
shut down the account entirely twice
they suspended it one of those
suspensions came after a complaint from
a Harvard Law instructor called
Alejandra Carl Barlow quote my report on
Libs of tick tock violating Twitter
rules got them suspended he bragged
Yet the woman who keeps runs lives of
tick tock kept going so ultimately Jeff
Bezos weighed in bezos's personal
newspaper The Washington Post decided to
harass the family of the woman who
operates lives of tick tock they
couldn't find her so they went after her
family the post sent what it calls its
Tech colonists Taylor Lorenz to show up
outside a home that belongs to one of
the woman's relatives
and then Lorenz set about trying to find
the woman herself she couldn't she sent
a direct message on Twitter to someone
who turned out to be not that woman I
had nothing to do with the account
whatsoever but because she did that we
know what Taylor wren's was saying
here's what she said quote you're being
implicated in starting a hate campaign
against
lgbtq people
right I hate campaign so here you have
Taylor Lorenz who's effectively acting
as the Stussy for the Deep State trying
to intimidate a private citizen
into silence
and this morning
she gave it her Best Shot The Washington
Post published a piece by Lorenz linking
to the name the physical address and the
real estate licensing information of the
woman who runs lives of tick tock after
the post published the article the woman
behind Libs of tick tock went into
hiding that was of course the whole
point of the exercise people know where
she lives because the Washington Post
linked to it so she had to leave now
Taylor Lorenz of all people knew this
would happen she knew what she was doing
when she wrote the story she was trying
to shut this woman up
it was just a couple of months ago you
might remember that Lorenz herself
complained on television that she was
being harassed and that no one under any
circumstances would be allowed to show
up at her home here she is
trolls live everywhere can you just
explain was like can you draw a picture
of what it is like when a surge of
harassment hits It's horrifying and it's
not just me either you know they
immediately docks you and go after your
family members they try and look up
everyone who's ever you know been
associated with you
um and it's just completely overwhelming
and terrifying
oh they go after your family members can
we put that picture back up it can
control them do that this is Taylor
Iran's outside the family members of the
woman who run Libs of tick tock the
other day harassing the family members
now the tape you just saw comes from
January then in April just eight days
ago Taylor Rentals who could not stop
talking about herself drowning in like
me
cried on television
because she'd been criticized online
watch I've had to remove every single
social tie I had severe PTSD from this I
I contemplated suicide it got really bad
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying it's horrifying
it's overwhelming it's really hard
it's really hard to be from Granite
should work for the Washington Post it's
hard no power
but if you really think it's hard if
you're really against that kind of
behavior why are you engaging in it at
scale
so a few weeks later after shooting that
performance Taylor Wren shows up at the
door and there's the picture right there
of a relative of the private citizen who
post videos to Taylor lorenza's bosses
don't like and then she posts that
person's identity online
so this is obviously an intimidation
campaign designed to shut down a highly
effective Twitter feed
but take one step deeper into the story
and ask yourself to tailor Lorenz the
woman you just saw crying on TV because
she has PTSD did she really do the
reporting here did she really track down
the personal information of the woman
who runs Libs of tick tock please
of course not she couldn't tolerance is
not a reporter apart from whining about
herself on television she has no skills
she couldn't do a weather forecast in a
rainstorm she's not a journalist
she's merely a receptacle for
information that other people gather for
their own ends a willing receptacle so
where did she get this information who
gave her the identity of the woman who
runs Libs of tick tock well actually we
don't have to guess because today's
Washington Post story answers that
question the post piece tells us that
information came from a man called
Travis Brown Travis Brown runs the quote
Travis Brown hate speech tracker which
uses a variety of proprietary methods to
reveal personally identifying
information of private citizens who
stray from the approved storyline
now who pays for all this that's the
question well the Travis Brown hate
speech tracker is funded by something
called the Prototype fund here's how the
Prototype fund describes the point of
Travis Brown's project quote prominent
right-wing extremist accounts on Twitter
and Facebook have developed a
well-documented pattern to distribute
controversial and extremist content to
their followers and then delete it
before moderators have the opportunity
to react to in other words before it can
be censored archiving is an important
element in counteracting this behavior
and has in many cases led to prominent
victories in the fight against the
Supreme extreme right
extreme right so not all hate speech is
the same the hate speech tracker does
not Target the hate speech of BLM riders
or antifa no only enemies of the Biden
Administration and the guys at Davos
how do they do it well Brown's methods
according to him including using
automated software to save user account
names and social media posts long after
they have been deleted so there's no
hiding from these people now that
appears to be a violation of Twitter's
terms of service not that we care
because they don't care we reach out to
Twitter about this isn't this a
violation they ignored us they suspended
our account
what's interesting though is that Travis
Brown himself appears to be a former
Twitter employee so again who's paying
for this
well a foreign government is paying for
it the Prototype fund gets its money not
from private donors but from the
government of Germany
Germany's federal Ministry of Education
it says so right on the website
in other words what happened to the
woman who runs lives of tick tock her
life being destroyed was not the work of
Taylor Lorenz The Fearless journalist
who cries on TV from a PTSD no it was a
foreign intelligence operation designed
to silence and intimidate an American
citizen wait is that legal
did the Biden Administration have any
role in this particular Intel op why is
the German government trying to shut
down an American Twitter account posting
about American teachers and since she
was the recipient the Willing recipient
of this information from a foreign
government designed to destroy an
American citizen why hasn't Taylor
Iran's at the very least registered
under the foreign agent registration act
Farah we seem to remember quite a bit of
talk about this over the last space we
think there was an impeachment trial of
it someone went to prison because of it
but Taylor Lorenz can take information
from a foreign government to crush an
American citizen clearly as part of an
Intel operation
and she's a journalist in good standing
at the Jeff bezos's newspaper
lots of questions here we hope we can
get the bottom of all of them subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight